he's the boy who described murdering his
teacher as fine and dandy
wilcornick just 15 when he stabbed dan
mcguire to death
in front of a classroom full of fellow
pupils
family and friends of the teacher
gathered united outside court having
just heard the details of her last
moments of life
we wish that nothing of ann's life be
lost
that we will
that she will be remembered
as a life's partner
a mother
a sister
a nana an
auntie
and genuine teacher
with a generous spirit who led by
example
they had just seen pictures of the spot
where ann maguire was stabbed to death
taken not long after her murder one
featured the classroom chairs as they
had been scattered by pupils fleeing the
horror unfolding before them
a much loved teacher being stabbed
repeatedly to the enduring trauma of the
family who followed the graphic account
in court
the joy of living her life
and the fulfillment of her hopes and
dreams and passions have disappeared
with this horrific cruel
senseless and currently act
the tragedy continues as the lives of
all those closest to on have been
shattered we shall never recover from
this pain and anguish
no amount of punishment
can ever compensate for the loss of
anne's life
she was a devoted and caring teacher
whose 40-year-long career was meant to
be in its final months
her killer was once regarded as a model
pupil polite and happy the son of
parents described in court as decent and
loving
but for reasons which may never fully be
revealed he developed an irrational
hatred towards his spanish teacher
another teacher here at corpus christi
school in leeds had once described the
pupil as delightful
but disturbing events were emerging
the 15 year old boy told classmates that
he wanted mrs mcguire dead even on
christmas day last year he exchanged
facebook messages with a friend in which
he spoke of his teacher's brutal killing
in february this year he posted another
facebook message in which he said mrs
mcguire
deserves more than death
more than pain
torture
and more than anything that we can ever
understand
was the symbol on his facebook page the
typical work of a teenaged boy or a
glimpse into the darkness of his
innermost thoughts
as the teacher fled her attacker he
pursued her along a school corridor she
told a colleague he's stabbed me in the
neck
that colleague susan francis pushed her
into a nearby room holding the door shut
with her foot
as the teacher was dying her attacker
returned to the room where he'd been
working and spoke two words to the
entire class
good times
as another teacher took hold of him he
said
can you be careful my knuckle is hurting
and my hand is bleeding
in later conversations with
psychiatrists he said i wasn't in shock
i was happy i had a sense of pride i
still do
i did not have a choice it was kill her
or suicide
he went on to say
i know the victim's family will be upset
but i don't care
in my eyes everything i've done is fine
and dandy
the family's ongoing grief was summed up
in a statement to court by mrs mcguire's
husband don
now all our dreams are gone forever he
said present and future are but words
the school boy who took it all away was
said by the judge to have enjoyed the
public nature of his crime
mike mccarthy sky news
leads